Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
this week at my round table of dining.
And Rhett, I can't actually see your table
from my live chat screen
Same table.
Same table as last time--
Okay.
I've got the square original
The classic card table
Original round table.
Yes.
but hey, I've switched rooms
man. As you can see,
I am in front of my own skin wall.
Yeah, you are, You're halfway
skinned, halfway unskinned.
I came in here because I thought
there might be better acoustics.
I don't know if there is--
there's a rug
I think it's still pretty.
There's a rug,
there's also a child's bed.
Which, I came in here and I was like,
Yeah, there's a single bed--
Link has put a ch...
I wouldn't call it a child's bed.
It is a child's bed.
It is a white bed that has drawers
on one side of it.
Every characteristic about
this bed is a child's bed.
It's a single bed and yeah,
it's got drawers underneath,
it's an Ikea bed, that--
It's kind of a vibe-killer.
It's kinda, I just gotta
be honest with you.
It's kind of a vibe-killer.
Well, it was in my garage,
and it's kind of a garage-killer.
And I'm like, you know what,
what, I bet you in that creative house,
we could use a bed.
That is the bed that when Britton lived
in my closet for over a year,
I call it a closet, but it
was just like an office,
a very small office.
It barely fit that single bed
and enough--
It quite barely fit Britton too
based on the length--
Enough room to walk.
Listen, I slept in a single
bed until I got married.
All the way through college.
Well I slept in a single bed
So did you.
But it was extra long--
Extra long?
I couldn't sleep in this bed.
I mean, I could I guess
I could sleep on my side,
but I mean I just...
Now that we have done anything
over here that makes--
We haven't done anything
over there, it's just a bed and a room.
Right, but like, I know,
but it could be like,
a cool couch that you could also sleep on
unlike a bed, a child's bed.
A bed, I mean, we don't need a bed.
It--
We'll talk about this later.
I didn't need a bed in my garage
so I put the bed over there.
Have you laid on that bed?
Well let's sell it.
It's a nice,
it's got a nice mattress on it, it's nice.
I haven't laid on it,
I just moved it, cause it was right here.
And you know,
oh, you moved it?
I moved it to the other side
That's right.
Yeah, cause this,
it was up against my skin wall.
You bedded my skin wall
Well, I wouldn't put it in those terms.
We, typically my thought--
Okay, what are we
talking about?
Are going in an effort to continue
to have a sense of connection
emits such isolation.
We ask you Ear Biscuit to you
to set up some topics of conversation,
some questions that we could discuss
between the two of us.
and we've got some...
We got some good
conversation starters here.
We got some good questions from you guys.
You wanna get into the first one?
Hold on. Well, did we,
Did you give the prompt?
Or we just, I mean, you kinda
gave a version of the prompt.
I didn't, I don't remember
what the prompt was honestly.
I think it was.
You've been in isolation.
Yeah.
Or you've had a lot of time
What do you mean?
To think about things.
What have you been thinking about alone
that we could talk about together?
And Jenna Tempkin--
I'll give you definitively
correct answers .
She says, "If you had an
opportunity to go back and relive
"a part of your life, would you?"
By doing so just to clarify, she says,
"It wouldn't change the present.
"You would do it more to
relive an amazing experience
"or event that you forget.
"If so, what part of your
life would you choose?"
Now I love questions that
don't have consequences.
'Cause, you know,
I'm sure in the past
we've talked about like
time travel or like
we definitely talked
about points in our past
that we've experienced.
But--
We've definitely talked
about points in our past
that we've experienced.
That's kind of our entire
existence at this point--
But I think maybe we've
talked about reliving stuff
but I always get wigged out about,
is it going?
Or what are the ramifications, you know?
Yeah, the fact that--
Let's just remove those.
She took that completely out.
Yeah, so first of all, I mean,
I think that for me immediately
when you add the qualifier
of you won't change it,
well, of course,
if I had the option
to just go back--
Yeah.
And relive one moment, of
course, I'm gonna do it.
But I have to choose one moment.
Oh, yeah, I know. It's like...
Do you have something in mind
'cause I'm having difficulty
narrowing it down--
Yeah, I do have something.
And you might think
that it would, you know,
some of the typical
answers that come to mind
are things like, well,
at the very first moment,
I met my wife, or my wedding
day, or the birth of my kids,
one of that I have to choose one.
And while all those would
be candidates for me,
I feel like...
I don't feel like in the moment
that those things were happening,
and this may be a reason
to go back to them.
I don't feel like I was
thinking the right things
in those moments
or like really like,
experiencing them in the right way.
But when I did start
thinking about a moment where
in the moment I said to myself,
"This is as good as it gets."
I have a candidate--
Okay, okay.
You were there.
You were there, but you
were tangentially there.
We were surfing--
Should I guess?
Oh, we were surfing, okay.
I know, okay.
And--
I think I know
what you're gonna say.
And I caught a wave and a
dolphin caught the wave with me.
Yeah. And I was there,
and you were by me.
And surfed with me.
And you told me afterward.
"Did you see that?"
And I was like, "Yeah,
I saw you catch a wave
"and it was great."
And you said, "There was
a dolphin in the wave."
And I did not see that.
So can I go back--
Yeah.
To see the dolphin?
Well, I mean, you should
probably have your own
that doesn't involve
watching me do something.
When you go back, I'll be there.
So I want you to say,
on this next wave,
look for dolphins in the wave.
And then in the future,
which is now as we're
having this conversation,
my answer might be,
"Remember that time that I
saw that dolphin in the wave
"and I swam over to it?
"And you were riding the wave,
"and I was riding the dolphin?
Well, but here's the thing,
by doing that, you would--
Change something.
Even though you said you
said you wouldn't change it,
you would change the moment if
you try to ride the dolphin.
Because I was riding the
wave and it was like,
you know, we hadn't
been surfing that long,
like catching a wave,
and like really catching a
wave was still a big deal,
and it was one of those
days where it was just
a low, long, slow--
Yeah.
Strong wave, so you had time to like think
and experience it, you know?
And then I look down
and there's a freaking,
the smartest mammal in
the ocean, besides me ,
is just sitting there just
hovering in the water next to me,
going the same speed.
And I was like,
"It can't get any better than this."
You know what will
This is it, man.
make it better?
Your life just peeked.
If it was nighttime,
and you were surfing on one of those waves
and dolphin was in it,
but it was one of those
iridescent glowing waves
that's happening off the
coast of California right now.
Like there's people--
is it still happening?
And you know, I don't know if
it's still happening but...
But I think it was a short window.
As of like within the
past week it was happening
and I wanted to drive and see
that but I have not done that.
But, of course they're opening,
they've opened the California beaches
for you can't sunbathe,
but you can surf and you can jog.
You can do like activities.
And guess who bought a new surfboard?
You did?
Your buddy.
You bought a new surfboard?
I bought a regular
You haven't even been using
the one you got.
I bought a regular surfboard.
I bought an 11 foot long board.
Because I'm going to,
I have to to do regular surfing man,
I have to learn,
I have to get where I don't
have to have the paddle.
Because I want to be
able to go to like Malibu
and surf without people
looking at me like I'm a dork.
I have to do that.
I have to get to that place.
Yeah.
I've made up my mind.
So what are you gonna do?
You're gonna start surfing
you're gonna ask me to go
and then I'm gonna be out
there on a paddleboard.
You didn't even include me in this.
Now if I'm gonna go out there
I'm gonna be that guy with a paddleboard.
Well the places that we typically go
there's a lot of people with paddle boards
and there's also people who go out
one person's on a paddleboard
and like somebody else is
not on the paddleboard.
I think that's fine.
It's just if I get where I'm good,
and then I'm like,
"Hey man, I'm going to Malibu."
At that point you have to make a decision
and by the way, I have another
And that will be kinda late.
Well, you told me that you can't paddle
because of your shoulders.
So I don't know what to do about that.
I think that's it. Yeah,
I just, I don't know what to do--
I've been practicing.
I've been practicing my pop ups.
I've been just out in
the yard just popping up.
So you you ordered a surfboard
and it was delivered to your house.
a big honking surfboard?
11 feet, Yes. It's a really, really long
but I'm a very, very big man.
You can probably paddleboard it.
It's basically a paddleboard
without a paddle--
My paddleboard
is not even that long.
No. It's longer, it's longer
or at the same length as
my existing paddleboard
but it's much narrower.
Well, I definitely miss going surfing
and now they've opened up to surf,
so you can go surfing.
Yeah, yeah I was gonna tell you
next chance we get we should go.
And I'm gonna go on my
existing paddleboard.
The thing that I probably
have lost the ability to do
'cause it's been so long since we've been,
but I'll probably pick it up faster
than you will try to tap on
one of those non-paddle boards.
Here's the thing.
I'm just gonna wait
If you just take off with it
then I'm gonna be tempted.
I'm gonna be tempted to try it.
I don't wanna be left in the--
And it's not like,
I didn't get like, I still got a surf top.
I didn't get like,
I mean I got like a surf tech.
Is that like the Walmart
brand or something?
No, it's like the kind you learn on.
Okay.
You know, it's still very,
not intimidating and like if
I hit somebody with the board,
they're not gonna die.
You won't kill him.
Okay.
Yeah.
But eventually I will get a board
that I could kill people with.
My dad told me that,
we moved to California
when I was three years old.
I remember not at three but like at five,
my dad was talking about
the surfers at Malibu,
he was like, "You realize
that if you go out there
"and you get in the way the surfers,
"they have really sharp boards
"and they'll shoot the board
into your head and kill you?"
On purpose?
On purpose.
As opposed to on purpose
which is what I would be if
I went back to relive that memory.
On purpose
It's interesting that you,
Okay, that you picked that.
See cause my mind immediately went to
things in my past that were
extremely meaningful experiences
that I don't think I
approached it correctly,
which you alluded to.
So--
Yeah, yeah
and I'm too worried about that.
I'm too worried about going back
and I don't know,
I picked a moment where I
felt like I did appreciate it
in the moment,
so that I could just go
back and do it exactly
the same way again.
That's what struck me but
I get what you're saying.
Yeah and that is why the first thing
that popped into my
head was my wedding day
because I think, first of all,
I know that i didn't enjoy myself
I was like a nervous wreck
the night before the rehearsal dinner,
I was a nervous wreck,
you know, we've been through this
and you know, I just, I try
when I think back on that
I try to apply that to my life now
but it's so hard to be
in a moment and saying,
"You know what, I'm
gonna enjoy this moment."
Because whatever it is
that concerns you about it.
With the wedding day,
I can't even tell you everything
I was concerned about.
It was just everyone else's expectations,
which is totally wrong.
This is my day and Christy's day.
Why on earth am I so concerned about
everyone else's experience
and everything like that,
you know, I would totally
have them soaking in
and have a much better time.
I would also really get a kick out of
cause everybody that we both knew
pretty much was in attendance.
So, it would be a way to
rub elbows with everybody
and have I mean,
I had a moment with everybody
at the wedding reception.
And but it's like, I
don't even remember it.
It was such a blur.
So I think it's like a cheat code
to have one moment in time
or have access to everyone
up into that point in my life
that was meaningful.
I had a meaningful relationship
with who was there from my
past and my then present,
you know, so I think I've
hacked it with that one.
I think that's actually my choice--
Well, and the fact that you
couldn't change anything
so then you could go back
and it wouldn't just be about
savoring it and enjoying it,
you could also be like,
what if I did this like Groundhog Day,
there are no consequences.
What if I just dropped my pants
in the middle of my wedding?
Like wouldn't it be fun to see
how everybody would react--
That is my biggest regret--
that I didn't drop my pants
during my wedding ceremony.
No, but if there were no consequences,
wouldn't you just do
something to stir it up?
My hesitancy in choosing
a moment like that was,
if I go back too far,
I think I would just be
thinking about things like,
"Well, my body feels different
you know what I'm saying?"
Whereas going back to
surfing like three years ago
I was pretty much the same guy.
Like I wouldn't be thinking like,
"Man like I feel so spry right now,
"I'm gonna run," or you know,
whatever I might do
If we increased
our frequency of surfing,
the chances of that happening again are
it's not out of the question.
You know.
Oh, I know.
Surfing with dolphins is actually
yeah, it's something that happened.
So--
It could happen again.
Yeah.
But I'm not getting married again.
We surfed with dolphins
And I'm not planning on it.
Multiple times.
Of course I'll be out
there on a paddleboard
and like I'll be able to go with the pad
and you'll be just,
you'll be all alone.
I am worried about
Trying to figure it out.
being in shape enough.
It wears you out.
Yeah, I just don't, my shoulders
and just like upper body strength,
like, I don't have any chest muscles.
I don't think you need
I don't think you need them.
When I went to my--
You just need endurance
Physical therapist guru,
you know, in addition to all
the things that I told you
that she told me about inviting
my weird rib to the party.
How's that going?
Has it come to the party yet?
I don't, I can touch it now a little bit.
I can touch my rib now.
I'm touching it right now
but it still freaks me out.
The first thing she did was she said,
"You don't have any chest muscle."
It's like your shoulder--
All right, thanks a lot.
She was like,
she basically told me I had a bird chest.
And I paid her for that.
Right.
You know, I was paying her,
Some people pay for insults.
It's a thing.
I think it's like an S and M thing.
I would go back
So I guess that's my...
So I would go back to that
physical therapy appointment,
so I could...
That was a wild ride, man.
I mean, I missed my physical.
I noticed everything about
my life that was weird,
you know, that I don't
get to go out and do like,
be critiqued by my physical therapist
or, but we can go surfing.
But you know, and we'll
move on in a second
but the real thing that
got me going on this
getting a regular surfboard,
you know, first of all,
I had like a Foam board that is not
I went out on that one time,
I was just, I'm too big for it,
like it's not rated for
it was rated for like 200 pounds.
I weighed like 220.
I needed like a legit
board that'll hold me up.
But the thing I was thinking is that
we've got these ideas
we've been talking about,
with like, we've got some
surfing-related ideas
that I actually wanna get serious about.
And they require,
like actually regular surfing
and not having your hands on a paddle.
And so I was like,
I just gotta learn how to do this.
Well, thanks for the heads
up, is all I'm saying.
I mean, would you have gone out?
You wouldn't have gone out
and bought a board.
No.
You would be like what!
You would have said,
"Well, let's see how you do with yours."
So that's why I haven't told you
but next time I go--
Here we are.
I'll just take my board
out and then eventually,
I'll get good and you'll be like,
"Man, you don't even have a paddle."
And I'll be like, "Yeah,
you can have this too."
Are you gonna let me try it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I might have some hidden,
hidden ability to do it all of a sudden
since the last time we did it.
It's all about we gotta
get in better shape.
It's all about endurance.
That's the only,
that's the X-Factor.
You just gotta have the ability
to get to there--
It's all about knowing--
And still have energy to stand up.
When to exert yourself.
Once you understand how to do something,
then you can channel your exertion
and not waste a bunch of energy
doing all the wrong things.
You know, that's true with
any type of physical thing.
You know, I'm an athlete, I
understand these principles.
And I actually have been
watching YouTube videos
about and we did so many things wrong
on that day we went out
with regular boards,
so many things wrong.
Oh, yeah.
So many things wrong.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll show you the YouTube videos.
I can benefit from that.
We got another question--
Okay.
About music I'm excited about,
but first, let's promote
some Merch, check it.
We're bringing back the mythical,
the mythical, we're associating mythical
with the clown shark in a shirt.
Well, yeah,
speaking of the see creatures,
There it is.
Which is you know, it's interesting.
That's one of the things
that Locke said about surfing
because I was like, "Hey, you
know, maybe later this summer,
"it's just the beaches are open
"and now I've got these,
"I've got two other Foam
boards that are like smaller,"
I was like, "Hey, me and
you and Shepherd could go.
"We could do some surfing together."
He's like, "Dad, sharks."
He's like, "I'm really scared of sharks."
and I'll be honest with you.
Oh, yeah.
You think about it a lot.
And there was at one time in Santa Cruz,
where I surfed a little bit that summer.
And there was a guy watching us surf
and then it was a big group of
people, you know, Santa Cruz.
And then when we got out he was like,
"Yeah, you know, there was a
great white circling all of you
"the whole time you were surfing."
'Cause he could see from the cliff.
Did you believe that?
So it does happen.
Yeah, I mean, it does happen,
but they don't, they
very rarely attack, man.
They're just clowns.
They don't attack on your shirt.
Mythical.com, check out all
the stuff we got over there.
You'd be surprised If you haven't
checked it out in a while.
Look at our store mythical.com
You'd be surprised.
Rep your boys.
Mythical.com, you'd be surprised
Tee up another one.
Okay.
JaeTee1. "Why is the music of
the 70s, 80s and 90s so good?
"Is it just nostalgia?
"Or is it because music was
truly epically good then
"and now it's just not
as good slash harder
"to find good music.
"Oftentimes, the music now that is good,
"has strong influence
from the 70s, 80s or 90s."
Well, first of all, I
agree that the 70s and 80s
are good in terms of music.
Now, 90s I feel like you
gotta be more specific,
in order to say it's good.
I don't think everything
in the 90s is good.
And I think that kinda
gets at where I ultimately
am gonna pick apart JaeTee
with an a and an e stands on this.
So my interpretation, I agree with you.
And I think the reason
for that perspective,
which a lot of people have,
I've got two thoughts on this.
The first is, the further you
get away from a time period,
the more it crystallizes.
Yeah. And you're not hearing
like only what's worthy
of sticking around, has stuck around.
So when you think of that decade,
you only think about the stuff
that stood the test of time.
It has staying power.
Yeah. So it's not that the 70s or the 80s,
I mean, well, first of all,
it probably did have less music
and there is more that which is a factor,
there's more and more music
It is, yeah.
because it's easier and easier
to make music independently
than it was back in the day.
So as time has passed,
there's just more and more music.
So I guess it's easier for
something to stand out.
But it isn't like there wasn't
a lot of different music
happening in the 70s or the 80s.
It's just not all that stuck around.
And we're still pretty close to the 90s.
Like, you know, people like us,
we were in high school,
we were in college at that time.
Now, I'll make a tangential statement,
which I think might be controversial,
or at least people will disagree with it.
I think that hip hop now
is better than it's ever been.
Period. So to me, this is an exception.
This is my personal exception to this
is that it's the best it's ever been.
I mean, when you go back and listen to,
when you listen to hip hop,
it's very, especially like early hip hop,
I'm talking like 80s.
Yeah, I mean, if you go
back to the inception,
it's very exciting to listen to
from a nostalgic standpoint
because it was just starting to bud,
and now it's blossomed
in all different genres,
and it changes so fast
it makes use of...
It seems like everything that catches
leads to the next thing
and benefits from it.
I mean, I love music
for a number of reasons,
but I love that aspect of it.
When JaeTee was talking about
the strong influence of
the 70s, 80s and 90s,
or basically you're just
saying music influences music
influences music, and it moves forward,
but I just feel like now
there's so much to enjoy,
and there's so many sub-genres
of hip hop that early on,
like classic, you just didn't, you know,
it was still forming.
And so there's more to enjoy.
It's better now especially because
it's the whole conceit of hip hop,
from a production standpoint
is taking things and then
repurposing and remaking them,
you know, between sampling and splicing
and looping and all of that.
I just think it's better.
Well, okay.
I have but the second part of my thought
actually ties into what
you're talking about.
And I'm gonna use the
NBA as an analogy, right?
And we both been watching The Last Dance,
which I hope that wasn't
gonna be your wreck.
We can talk if it was
But it could be.
We can tease a wreck, go for it.
So if you care about sports,
and based on the couple of times
I've said things about sports on Twitter,
I get the impression that
the mythical beast herd
is not a lot of sport's fans,
but there are some,
but this Last Dance ESPN
documentary about the bulls,
Chicago Bulls and Michael Jordan,
is phenomenal, is one of the
best things I've ever watched
in entertainment, period.
If you're into basketball
Absolutely!
And you're our age,
so if you can, if you
lived through those seasons
in the--
Yeah.
That was what? 98/97.
Yeah and they go through the whole,
they basically go through Jordan's career,
but they really focus on the 97/98 season.
Now, one of the things that
comes up a lot of times is,
this, you know, hypothetical conversation
about how good would Jordan be now
and this is one of the,
and I know you're
watching it with Lincoln,
I watch it with Locke.
And so we're watching it
with these teenage boys
who are really into
basketball, love the NBA.
And, you know, Locke kept
leaning over during this thing,
he's like, "I just didn't
know he was that good."
I just, I didn't appreciate
how good Jordan was.
Yeah.
Now, but then when you ask
the hypothetical question of
well, how would Jordan
be if you just took him,
literally you took 1995 Michael Jordan,
and you just put him on an
NBA court now, you know.
That's it. He just he's there.
How would he do?
And I feel pretty strongly
that he would just be sort of a middle
of the road player, initially.
Now, I think that he would
adjust pretty quickly
and become one of the,
he would become an all-star, most likely.
But it's not a cut and dry situation.
Now, the reason I say that is
and you actually get this when
you watch the documentary.
You know, Jordan wasn't playing basketball
in the off season.
He didn't even start lifting weights
until he lost to the Pistons
two years in a row.
Yeah.
And was pissed off about it.
Pistons I'll say.
Yeah, the system that generates
basketball players now
is a completely different
system that has been fine-tuned.
You know, he didn't even make his varsity,
the story goes, you know,
in that they talked about the documentary.
He didn't make his varsity
team in his sophomore year.
But now kids who are going to be
and you look at the other
Bulls like Scottie Pippen
going to like Central
Arkansas or whatever.
And then like Horace Grant
went to some other school
that nobody, a small school.
That doesn't happen anymore,
because the system that
creates these NBA players
at that level, their
nutrition, their fitness,
their practice, their
insights that they get,
their coaching, everything
has been fine-tuned,
and it is definitively better.
Now, you might be like,
"It's not as rough or whatever."
But if you were to take LeBron,
as developed as he is,
and you just throw him
back into that system,
I think he would dominate
even more than he does
because of the system
that he's come up in.
Now, I think the same holds true in music
and what you're, but I think
there's something special
about that time,
because one of the things
that makes it so special
is that the opportunity to innovate
and stand above the competition,
and the way that Jordan did,
is something that is so hard to do,
there's not gonna be
another Michael Jordan
because the delta on the
opportunity for innovation
is smaller than it's ever been
because the system is so efficient
at producing excellence, right?
And so I think the same
thing has happened in music,
and also the accessibility
for people to create music
on their own, has gotten
where we are just overwhelmed
with really, I mean,
there's a lot of good music,
there's also a lot of bad music,
because there's so much opportunity.
And I just think we've gotten to a place
where finding the special
connection with music
is harder to do than it was at that point.
And it doesn't mean that
it's not good or better
or the music was,
but the music was, let's
just say more special
back when the threshold or the threshold,
the barrier to entry to
actually make music was bigger.
Yeah.
That's my theory.
Okay well there's two parts to that.
I mean, I think I agree that the fact that
there's so many more
artists who can be heard
that it's hard for any
one artist to really pop,
I mean of course it still happens.
I mean you've got superstars.
You've got your Lady
Gagas, you got your Drakes.
But does it feel different
than back in the era of Michael Jackson?
Yeah, because there's still...
There's still so much competition.
Right
I mean, Drake can't go away
that long. He's you know,
his features have to be
just as a groundbreaking
as his own albums, or mixtapes,
and you know, it has to keep coming
in order to remain relevant.
You just can't,
you've gotta work really hard for that
because there's so much competition.
The part about the system though,
I think the analogy doesn't work there.
I mean, if you look at,
if you just look at country music
and how The Nashville Sound came about,
and there was a whole,
there was a manufacturing
process around that,
around the early days of rock and roll,
I mean, you got the, you know,
you've got Glen Campbell
and the name's leaving me at this point,
but like the super group
of studio musicians
who are just creating this churning,
they just show up every day
and churn out these tracks
for some singer-songwriter,
or somebody who's a pretty
face or a pretty voice.
So there was a machine for decades--
But it was machine based,
but it was a machine based on pure talent
like Glen Campbell is sitting there,
like physically interacting
with a sonic instrument to make noise.
Whereas now a 12 year-old is in his room
with GarageBand and creates something.
And it's just like,
it's not that
it doesn't take talent
By the way I was talking
about the Wrecking Crew,
the Los Angeles studio
based crew that brought in,
that's not country music, but they--
But don't you think that that's...
I guess what I'm saying is
and maybe this does go against my analogy,
I think that that the Wrecking
Crew was doing something
that's more special
than the 12 year-old in
their room with GarageBand.
Well, no, yeah,--
I'm not saying--
that it's not awesome--
I'm saying--
But I'm just saying it's not,
it isn't a special because
how many Wrecking Crews
can there be?
Well, there's only unlimited number
of how many there can be.
But how many 12 year-olds
They turned out
a bunch of stuff.
Can get GarageBand? Millions.
Yeah they made a lot of hits but.
Again, I think it's a,
but there are still people
who are making amazing music
using those tools
and there's a lot more
opportunity for true artists
to come out of the woodwork
and I think that there're,
you know, I think it,
but we're so close to it,
you know, I think time will tell.
Time will tell if,
are we gonna be listening
to My Strange Addiction,
you know, 20 years from now.
Probably.
I think that
I think so
The simple fact that there's
it's so clouded with so
many more options over time
and because of the
revolution of digital music,
digital music that
replicates analog music.
I feel like you're gonna look back
and it's gonna be much
more difficult to recognize
the sound of a decade.
I think that the recognizing
the sound of a decade
is something that
potentially died in the 90s.
I don't know if it made it
into the new millennium.
I just think it--
'cause what's the difference
I just think we're too close to it.
I mean,
What's the difference
between, what is the sound of the 2000s
versus the sound of the 2010s?
What's the difference
between the last Justin Timberlake album,
which maybe is a bad example,
'cause I didn't listen to it,
versus the last NSYNC album, a whole lot?
You know, I think he was wearing like,
a flannel on the cover of that album.
I was like, "Say something
about the woods."
I mean, I didn't listen to that one.
So I don't know, but.
Well, you were right time will tell.
I'm just saying that
my theory at this point
is that it won't,
there won't be a definitive
like when you think 50s Music,
what do you think?
You think like Dubois, right?
Not as good.
You know, when you think 60s music,
you think like
Late.
Starting to get interested like
Okay,
Weird, hippies.
Late 60s it gets real good.
Yeah.
That's when music started
to get real good.
But it wasn't before,
I mean, in my opinion,
it wasn't before then.
But then there's always something
that's gonna grip you since then.
There's a lot, but it's really splintered.
And I think that just to wrap it up,
I think that most of what grabs me
is the stuff that is
calling back to the times
where I thought that music was special.
So there for me,
there's not a whole lot of music
that's being made that isn't
really heavily influenced
by something in the past,
that I'm really into.
Like I'm not into any new genres.
No, I think that but the phrase,
"Influenced by the past it."
Why do you have to say that?
Just like, of course,
Well, no, no, what I'm
saying is that like--
Of course, everything is
influenced by something.
All music is influenced by something.
So I don't think
But some things are,
some things are more of a departure
from the past than others.
Some things call back more thoroughly.
So in other words,
like, I'm not, I'm not an EDM fan,
because it's very difficult for EDM
to capture much of anything from the past
because it's a very futuristic,
forward-looking genre,
but I just don't,
there's no soul in it to me.
I don't connect with it.
But that's your problem.
Maybe something's wrong
with me.
Yeah, I mean in a--
But do you you like EDM?
I don't know enough, no.
And I don't know enough about it.
But I'm not gonna say that
it's not influenced by stuff
because it absolutely has to be
Oh it's clearly influenced by stuff,
but it's a more bold departure
than say Jason Isbell.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
You know.
Like, I mean, I haven't listened
to a lot of Kraftwerk either
but it's like, I mean,
What is that?
Kraftwerk, I think had to influence
all electronic music from the 70s.
What is Kraftwerk?
Kraftwerk is...
Kraftwerk with a K and then an E.
Is it a band?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah, German band formed in 1970.
While it considers innovators and pioneers
of electronic music,
they were among the first successful acts
to popularize the genre.
It's just you're not
into electronic music.
No.
But I mean,
you'll like the Daft Punk
album, just like I will.
But it's just not your thing.
But when it's not our thing,
And why do I like the Daft Punk album?
Because it is by definition,
a strong throwback to the 70s in disco.
And it even has the
story of the connection
to the original pioneers of disco,
in the album built into the album.
They tell the story so from
and that connects back to a time
when I was actually alive.
I was a little tiny baby.
I don't think
that's what the story is.
I think it's the inventor
of the synthesizer.
I'm just saying it's a different thing
we don't know
as much about it.
But he talks about that beat
the Click Track and stuff.
I'm just saying that,
like it's literally a throwback,
and it's got a historical angle.
And that's why we like it.
But if things get too on the
cutting edge of the future,
we don't like it anymore.
And unless you're really, really hip,
and I don't wanna be that hip.
I'm not that dad.
I don't know, I think
We can talk about,
we could have easily made this
into an episode, by the way.
And we just made it into one question,
so maybe we'll have to
come back to this subject.
Well, you know, for the
next listening party,
Britton and I are working,
we were like, "We gotta do something,
"we gotta do some music that's now."
So I think by the time this comes out,
it would have come out
but we decided we were
only gonna play music
for each other that is music that's moving
that's now like brand new music.
Like over weeks or months old.
And I had to get excited
about it in a different way
because it was more difficult
to get excited about
but there's lots of
music that's moving me.
'Cause it can happen.
Yeah, I mean, yeah, I agree.
Let's move on to another question.
This one is from Rapha Conrad.
"What is your perspective about fandoms?"
Okay, it's interesting
cause I've been thinking
more about fandoms lately
because, and I think
this is true for you too,
I'll just speak for myself.
I wouldn't consider myself,
I've never experienced
being a part of a fandom.
Now, obviously, I'm
excluding the fact that,
you know that, there's a
fandom around what we do.
There's a mythical fandom.
I'm very grateful for that
and I'm very reverent towards
how people have created it as a fandom,
but I observe it from the,
I don't wanna say from the top, down
or from the outside, in,
but like, I mean, a fandom formed
around the stuff that we create,
but I don't, even though
I'm very passionate
about a lot of things,
I don't think that I could say that
I've ever actually been
a part of a fandom.
And I will tease that,
I gained some insight through
some recent experiences,
which I'll talk about in a second,
but I just wanted to put
that out there first.
Have either one of us ever
been a part of a fandom?
And how do we define fandom?
Do we need to look that up like Kraftwerk?
I mean, you can look it up
but I'll give you my layman's definition.
You can see if Google agrees with me.
Yeah.
I think it's a group
of people who have
connected with each other
because they have connected
with all connected together
around something else that they like.
Yeah. Fans of a particular person,
team, fictional series, et cetera,
regarded collectively as
a community or subculture.
Community
For me the community
aspect is the thing so,
I would consider, I'm probably,
the most I'm a part of a fandom
is a fan of NC State Athletics.
I mean, that's the easiest thing, right?
So my college, Lynx College.
So it isn't like I have a group of people
that I get together with and watch games,
but I have, like, you know,
a couple of our college buddies
that I'll talk to about a big game,
or something like that.
I mean, there's like a
group of NC State people
that get together at
like a bar and Pasadena
and watch,
Really?
Watch games together.
You ever thought about going?
And there was a time,
I've thought about it,
I don't think I'm gonna do it,
but I have thought about it.
Because you know,
especially when the thing about
being a part of a fandom is that,
you relate in this way,
and when you're an NC State sports fan,
you relate in a very particular way
of like having your hopes dashed
against the rocks of--
Yeah.
Reality over and over again
for decades and decades.
And that makes you a
certain type of fan, right?
And so there's a connection there,
just a like mindedness
that you don't even have to think about
when you meet somebody.
Oh, and if you see somebody with an NC,
like the thing is, is that like,
the block S from Stanford
is exactly the same as
the block S from NC State
except the NC State has N
and C kinda small in there.
And so, when I first moved out here,
I saw all these block S's
and I was like State, no Stanford,
State, no Stanford, State,
you never see somebody
wearing anything NC State,
but it's after maybe five
Until you do,
and it's like wow
And 10 years and I talked to these people,
Yeah, because
I talk to them
there's so much
And I don't talk to anybody.
It's, especially like, in medieval times,
if you get thrown in the dungeon,
you're like in the blocks
and you're like you're in the shackles.
What are you gonna do?
You're gonna start,
you're gonna start talking to the guy
or the girl next to you.
you're gonna, hey, you're
gonna connect in the misery
of being in that situation.
That's what it's like
to be a wolf pack fan.
And so, if you're gonna endure
the heart wrenching loss.
And you've opted out
I've opted out.
You've opted out of that.
I mean, I love NC State,
I love my experience,
but I just cannot,
when it comes to the sports experience,
I cannot stand being trampled.
And then getting my hopes up just enough
to think that is not gonna happen
the time after or the time after that.
Yeah, I get it.
But so yeah, there's a...
You have this need for a connection.
I mean, my insight came when
and you know, I was talking
about how Lily and I
started watching John
Mayer's live Instagram show
called Current Mood
which is roughly comes out every week.
You know, we're both
big fans of his music.
Our families are big fans of his music.
You know, we're middle-aged white guys,
what are we supposed to do?
Okay, you gotta like John Mayer.
But like our kids
are into it
You lose your card
if you don't like John Mayer.
Lily's really into it
and she got me into Current Mood.
And I've, it was such
a different experience
because, well it was live,
so there was like more of a connect,
we've done a lot of live stuff.
And we really built,
we really started to build our community,
when we were doing that
RhettandLinkKast live.
There is something
magical about knowing that
this is happening now,
and if I type something,
he might read it, he might respond to it.
There could be a little
conversation, some acknowledgement.
But even beyond that,
when an episode was over,
and I was reflecting on it,
I just started to appreciate
specifics about it.
Like why I was really into it.
You know, the fact that he
has a certain sense of humor,
but he also talks about
things that are serious,
and he processes things
in an interesting way.
And he thinks in a similar way to me,
I started to relate on that level,
and I started to become curious
how many other people had
that type of experience?
And here I'm in bed, I'm on Reddit anyway,
I bet you there's a John
Mayer Reddit thread.
I wonder if there's a
Current Mood Reddit thread
cause I didn't wanna just talk about
I didn't wanna be a fan of John Mayer,
I wanted to talk about
that show specifically
and like the episode I had just watched,
I found myself wanting to
discuss it with other people.
And there wasn't one.
There was a John Mayer Reddit thread.
And Some people would talk
about Current Mood but--
I was sure that you were
gonna say that there was.
So I actually found that I was frustrated
that there wasn't and
I ain't gonna start it,
I ain't got time for that.
But sometimes there's a Current Mood entry
in the John Mayer thread
and I don't even know what
John Mayer fans are called,
if they have a name.
Like how they associate
themselves in the fandom but,
again, I'm speaking of it as
if I'm not involved in it,
but, I've gotten as close as I have
to saying that I'm in a fandom
because I found myself
wanting to just talk to people
about somebody else's work
and connect over it.
And I don't think,
I mean, I really like connecting
and talking to people about music.
But music is not a fandom,
you know, it's gotta be a specific thing.
And it actually gets started--
You mean hold on,
you mean when you put
on your dating profile
that you like music,
that doesn't mean anything.
Right, right.
And for the record, I do
not have a dating profile.
So--
Right.
Rhett, I don't know what
Rhett's referring to.
But if you did, you wouldn't
say I'm really into music,
I would put I like listening to music,
that's a hobby of mine.
But when I say that, I really mean it.
Like I like to sit down
and listen to music.
And I like to think about it,
and I like to talk about it.
So I'm not some...
I'm not just somebody who
says, "Yeah, I like music,
"yeah I like food.
"I like to eat food,
"I like to listen to music."
Right.
I like sunshine.
But I started to think,
I gained insight into
how the mythical beast,
enjoy our content because there's
when you really get something,
and I feel like, you know,
the mythical beasts really get us.
I think that's what,
that's what it means
to be a mythical beast.
That you watch it and you
understand why it's...
They wanna connect to us.
They connect to what we create
they connect to who we are.
And I started to understand
There was a whole chapter
That for the first time.
in the book of Mythicallity
about this
Yes, somebody likes
what you like, then you like them.
Yeah, 'cause we talked
about Merle Haggard.
And I think that--
Right.
The thing that we didn't do,
me and you connected with each other
Right.
Over our love for Merle.
But we didn't connect
with a greater fandom
because when we went to the concert,
it was a bunch of 65 year-old people .
And I'm not Britton, you
know what I'm saying?
Like your cousin Britton will
go to a horror convention
and come back best friends
with a 94 year-old woman.
It's like you know, and that's awesome.
And I wish I was more open to
personal connection than that,
but I just, I'm not.
So it was like, "Oh, my friend likes this,
"this is something we connect."
But the greater community of people
who would call themselves
Mayerheads or whatever,
Mayers, maybe they just
call themselves Mayers.
They're all Mayers of Mayer
town. John Mayer fans.
I don't know.
To some extent it feels like a commitment.
It's the same reason I consider myself
an NC State sports fan,
but I don't go to that
bar to watch NC State lose
in sports with other people.
Because...
You gotta commit,
you gotta commit not just
to the thing that you like
you have to commit to the
other people who like it.
Yeah, there's a lot more time involved
and I think I found myself
if there was a John Mayer...
If there was a Current Mood discussion,
like that was reliable every week
like in this environment
right now being home so much
like I could see myself
starting to make friends
in that environment and start
you know, it's you know, Mike,
our friend science, Mike,
he's big into Dungeons and Dragons.
He talks to us about it,
but he talks about how he'll play,
and he has a group of
friends that he plays with
that some of them were
members of his community
who also like Dungeons and Dragons
who were part of that community.
So then they would form
their own little group,
but I mean, you got
the whole Trekkie thing
that was the quintessential beginning
of fandoms in my mind--
Con.
When you go to a convention,
and then you would be,
make friends with those
people, and that was,
but I think
in this environment
Hold on and by the way,
by con, I did not mean the Wrath of Khan.
I just meant conventions.
Yes, you did.
But there is a double meaning
and you have to specify when
you're talking about Star Trek,
or Star Trek, as I said,
until I was like 13.
But I don't know, I don't know,
maybe I need to go full in on a fandom
in order to then be a better,
what are we?
Figureheads of the mythical fandom?
Figurehead is someone who
really doesn't do anything
but it kinda--
There's a, there's a...
And careful with that.
There's a very specific opportunity,
given the fact that there's two of us,
because you could become part of my fandom
and I could become part of your fandom.
And that's how we fully
participate in the mythical fandom.
It's just like, hey, I'm a
big fan of the mythical stuff,
but really--
You're gonna start tweeting about it.
You know when Linc said
so and so so and so like,
what like, wasn't that cool?
I'm gonna start like a
Twitter account that's like
Link's Ocean Blue Eyes
or something like that.
And tweet about you constantly.
That's what I'm gonna do.
What are you gonna do about me?
I'm already really close
to being a Mayerhead.
I think that's where I'm gonna go.
Well, I'm not committing to you
if you don't commit to me.
We have enough commitments to each other.
We don't need to be till this biggest fan.
Okay, let's do one more question.
All right.
This one's from Michelle, very practical.
Thoughts about using a
blanket on the couch.
Does it need to be folded
or put away after each use,
even if you know you're going
to just pull it out next time?
My husband says yes but I say no.
I literally use a blanket
on the couch year round.
We use a blanket on the couch year round.
I mean, there's certain blankets
that our entire family has,
they considered the best blanket.
And so then we bought a weighted blanket
and for a little bit,
the weighted blanket
became the coveted blanket.
Everyone fought over,
you had to get on there,
you had to get underneath at
first as like calling shotgun.
But then turns out the weighted blanket,
was too heavy, too weighted.
So now the second most popular blanket
has now become the most--
Too heavy for who?
For most people,
it gets too warm
and you could injure yourself moving it.
I don't like the weighted blanket
because I can hurt my shoulders
trying to pick that thing up and move it.
I gotta preserve that for surfing.
How did you hurt yourself?
Well, I tried to move a weighted blanket.
So our second most popular blanket
became the coveted blanket again,
I'm looking at it over
there and it's gone.
Somebody's got it.
And we just bought a second one.
We should about five of them.
So I will say, there's always blanket
lying around.
When you watch
a movie together, everyone
has a blanket, all five?
Yeah, pretty yeah.
Yeah, it's interesting because
when we watch a movie together,
they all have blankets,
and I just don't quite get it.
I'm kinda like--
are you warm natured?
You're a little warm natured.
No, I'm actually, I get cold.
Most of the time when
you say that you're cold,
I'm like, when I think about it I'm like,
"Yeah, it is a little cold."
I just honestly--
You should get a blanket.
I don't think about it as
much and I like a blanket.
I think It's just,
I just assume that it's
not going to be big enough.
I just assume that all
blankets won't fit me
and so I just,
it's like, it's the reason I
don't try things on at stores.
I'm like, "It's not gonna fit me."
our favorite blanket is
big enough for you, man.
It's such a big blanket.
You can, I take that
blanket and I can hold it,
it's about, it's like
a six by eight blanket.
That would fit me.
Now, so we have a lot of blankets,
you know, on the couch.
Well, there's at least two.
For some reason, there's usually two
and since three of them want
blankets they get in fights,
and I don't know why we
haven't done the math on this
but my wife is cleaning up constantly,
and the rest of us are--
My kids significantly worse
than me, creating mess.
Yeah.
Right?
And it's interesting now given quarantine,
cause we don't have anybody over.
Right? So Jesse likes to
get the house real nice
for people who don't live in it .
Yeah.
You know.
And...
But we've been keeping it pretty clean,
but I gotta say that the blankets
have just been nonchalantly
thrown over the couch
and sort of left in place
for I'd say weeks now,
with no like, there's no
folding and putting away
and now if she gets
into a cleaning mindset,
they will be folded and put away,
only to be taken out again.
Even in this environment,
I think that creates a lot of problems.
I mean, you could anticipate
my position on this.
I think that blankets should be folded
and not put away
they should be folded--
What kind of problems?
When you walk up to a couch
and there's a blanket that
someone's been in on it
and it's like just like
a clump of blanket,
But folding doesn't make it cleaner.
It is not inviting because it says,
someone else has been in this,
someone else's bodies,
body smells and skin cells
and stuff is all in it.
Now, if you fold it up
that statement's still true,
but it doesn't--
It does and more so.
It doesn't make you think about it.
It doesn't--
but logically
Make you think
someone else has been
the skin cells
In this blanket
But the other parts of the
person that came off of them
and got on the blanket are now folded up
and they're multiplying,
when it's folded--
No they're not.
At least when it's out in
the open, they're dying.
The pieces of the person are dying
It's in a clump, it's like a brain.
It's mushed together and there's all
there's even more crevices.
There's even more crevices--
Do you think
the viruses that are on the people
are being crushed by the
blanket being folded?
Not true.
Well I don't wanna talk
about viruses at all.
I just think that it's
not inviting to go into,
like if a shirt is hanging
on a rack you're like,
"I could try that on."
If the shirts laying in the bottom of a,
you know, the stall,
"I don't wanna try that on."
Even though someone else has already tried
on both of those shirts to use your...
Okay, lemme ask you a different question,
that's related to this.
When your wife goes out of town
and you're at home alone,
do you make the bed and why?
I like to make the bed
because then if I take a nap,
I like to take a nap on top of the bed
because if I get under the covers
then that's not a nap, that's sleeping.
Well, I was trying to trap you
because your logic of other people's parts
doesn't apply when it's just
you sleeping in a bed, right?
I just think--
It's just your parts
It's just more exciting.
When you walk in a room and there's like,
there's a blanket here and it's folded
and there's a blanket draped
over here strategically.
It's like, oh, and then it also,
when something's in clumps,
it sends a signal to the other people
in the house, the kids,
that you know what though?
I can leave my chip bag here,
I can leave my half drunk
can of LaCroix here,
I can leave my full drunk can here.
Do you think a clean house
It sets a tone.
Starts with a clean bed?
Yes
Now listen.
It sets a tone.
I don't agree.
And as you might guess,
I do not make the bed when
I'm sleeping alone in it.
And my wife makes the bed,
literally, like she can't start her life
if the bed isn't made.
And every single time.
I don't do that.
I don't make the bed every morning.
But I do like a made bed.
But every single time
I'm participating in
the making of the bed,
because if I happen to get
caught in the room at the time
when she's doing it,
I got long arms,
I look like I'm made to make beds.
Yeah.
I have to help, I get recruited.
And every single time I'm doing it
I have a number of thoughts,
I'm flooded with thoughts.
One of them is, there's
got to be a better system.
Like there's got to be
something that is closer
to a sleeping bag.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I just, there's multiple sheets
and the way things have to fold down
and don't get me started on
a freaking down comforter,
I'm sure your wife has the same thing,
our wives get similar things.
Yeah.
But it's this down comforter
that has a duvet cover,
and then you have to pull it in
and then fold it backwards
and like tie it in a certain.
When we start doing that,
I start going ballistic every single time,
I'm just like, "I don't understand
why is this the system?"
This has been around
for who knows how many hundreds of years
and this is the way we're still doing it.
I would gladly make the bed
if it was like Jetsons time,
and we figured out a way
to just do it efficiently and cleanly.
But I get mad at the
antiquated nature of it,
and it just makes me
think, "I'm above this,
"I'll just come back to this tonight
"and I'll work my way into
it and it'll be fine."
We're talking about blankets though.
So I think the same thing applies,
of course, I think the same
thing applies to blankets,
if you're not gonna have guests
because I do agree that if
you go to somebody's house,
and you're like,
"Oh, there's a bundled up
blanket on their couch.
"that means somebody
drooled there, or worse."
But if it's just me and my family,
I know who was on the couch last night.
I was there, we were
watching a movie together,
after we argued about
which one it would be.
I don't make my kids
I don't need any blankets.
Fold blankets, I don't make them do that,
but I do it because I like it.
But I recognize it as a matter of taste.
So it makes me happy
but I don't enforce that on the kids
cause I don't think that would be fair.
So I think that's the compromise.
I admit that it's a matter of taste.
Well, so is Michelle
right or husband right?
Because that's really
what this comes down to.
You're saying that her husband is right.
I'm saying that
You know I don't think it's,
I think it's a matter of taste.
It's not a matter, you
have to live together,
and you know ,
Yeah, but I think
the situation here.
I think that the situation is easy.
If her husband believes that the blankets
need to be folded and put away,
well, he can do it.
That's what I'm saying.
Don't drag Michelle into it.
Yeah, I do agree with that.
And I'll give a little
Okay, we've solved problems
today
Wreak here.
Oh, yeah, wreak.
Thanks for giving us these,
these questions, these
topics of conversation.
I learned lots of stuff.
Sounds like I might get
to go surfing again soon.
A little wreck for you guys.
I mean, I could just
wreck that documentary
because, yeah, if you're our age,
and you were into basketball
and wanna relive the Jordan glory days,
that's great.
I think if you care about sports at all,
It's incredible
I'll make that the wreak.
The Last Dance.
I've got at least one more episode.
And like Phil Jackson is
an interesting person.
Like, we haven't talked
about this, but I'm like,
man, what a...
Someone who doesn't fit the
mold for his particular job.
Such an interesting guy.
I wish they would have
taught me more about him.
I wanna see a Phil Jackson documentary.
Well, you know, the guy who
directed The Last Dance,
also did a documentary on Andre The Giant.
I've seen that one then.
Yeah, that was good too.
But he's also done like
two or three other ones.
He just, cause he's,
I think he did one on The Pistons maybe.
He did one on another team.
I think that I could,
I don't think it has to
be the Chicago Bulls,
I think I'm really opening myself up
to sport's documentaries in general.
30 for 30s. All right, Last Dance,
that's our recommendation.
Hashtag EarBiscuits.
Let us know what you
think about these topics,
if that's blankets or
reliving a point in your life
or all the stuff we said about music.
Let us have it.
We'll speak at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
if you prefer to listen to this podcast.
It's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.